je ne suis pas là votre tête ni dans
votre peau mais j'ai honte pour vous on
de ce que vous défendez aujourd'hui on
monte de voir que vous avez renié
l'ensemble de vos projets on a une
réforme qui est terriblement comptable
et la justice elle est quasiment
inexistante je veux voir aujourd'hui
dans ce gouvernement faire en sorte de
faire de rogner complètement ce que vous
avez jusqu'ici été l'apôtre du progrès
social c'est un système injuste qui
était proposé puisque ce sont les si je
peux dire les moins modestes qui vont
financer la retraite des plus modestes
les effets de manche pour être applaudis
par un peu moins de la moitié de vos
groupes si j'ai bien compté les effets
de manche ne marche pas les procès
entrahon je suis immunisé surtout quand
ils viennent par ceux qui ont vendu
social démocratie à l'extrême gauche
pour sauver leur siège et je dis ce sera
une journée difficile à l'évidence un
jeudi noir je sais pas ça sera un joli
de galère ce sera un jeudi de fortes
perturbations dans les transports vous
êtes dans la roue de la France insoumise
vous vous faites marcher dessus par
Jean-Luc Mélenchon si les
sociaux-démocrate qui pour vous devrez
avoir honte les perturbations
s'annoncent massives dans les services
publics jeudi pour la première journée
de grève contre la réforme des retraites
sur les rails le trafic sera fortement
réduit avec seulement un TGV sur 3 sur
les axes Nord et sud-est je pense qu'il
faut toujours ouvrir une porte pour une
discussion qui ne portera sur quelques
sujets pas simplement la le report de
l'âge légal mais d'autres dispositions
une journée noire donc qui pourrait
naître que la première d'une longue
série ah bah nous ça va durer jusqu'à ce
que on gagne en fait ça passera
inévitablement par un mouvement
reconductible si le gouvernement reste
sur cette position de blocage et même de
passage en force la CGT mines vous avez
sans doute entendu parler de ça qui
menace de ce côté de coupure énergétique
contre les élus qui eux soutiennent la
réforme des coupures ciblées et
punitives donc
le stigmatisation politique en réalité
là je crois qu'on est plus dans le cadre
syndical on n'est plus dans le cas de
loi grève et ça c'est une acceptable
menacer les élus c'est un à mon avis un
mauvais objectif et c'est une modalité
qui n'est pas acceptable ces formes
d'action là même si elles sont radicales
à partir du moment où elle s'attaque pas
aux gens me paraissent pas
incompréhensible ou en tout cas ne
comptez pas sur moi pour les condenser
bien évidemment il y a un élu il fait
des mauvais choix et bien vous avez le
pouvoir par le par le vote qu'il ne soit
plus élu pas lui couper l'électricité il
faut lui couper simplement
le vote ça suffit les syndicats qui sont
dans une espèce de course à l'échalote
de concurrence syndicale pense que parce
qu'ils vont couper la lumière à orbergé
ça va la faire changer de position je
pense que on est loin du résultat
attendu on y voit une cliente d'un salon
de coiffure bouleversé d'avoir à se
raser la tête à cause d'un cancer dans
cette épreuve la jeune femme va recevoir
le soutien de son quelques mots de
soutien un câlin puis l'homme se rase la
tête à son tour un incendie
spectaculaire filmé hier par des
riverains
une épaisse fumée noire
le feu s'est déclaré dans un entrepôt de
batterie au lithium puis c'est propagé à
deux bâtiments voisins qui stockaient
des pneus et des textiles on ignore où
et quand cette vidéo a été prise mais la
publication récente de ce geste de
solidarité suscite beaucoup d'émotions
chez les plus de 10 millions
d'internautes qui l'ont vu